it's another step to put pressure on the
russian leader in alignment with the
decision by our european allies the
united states will join them in
sanctioning president putin and foreign
minister lavrov and members of the
russian national security team
24 hours after president biden said he
still had further options with sanctions
vladimir putin became one of only a
handful of world leaders to be
personally sanctioned by the u.s this
step sends a clear message about
the the strength of the opposition
to the actions by president putin and
the direction
in his leadership of the russian
military the u.s president talked with
president zielinski for 40 minutes on
friday he promised to continue
humanitarian military and security
support but what isn't clear from the
white house reading of the call is if
they discussed moscow's offer of peace
talks an offer dismissed by the u.s
state department
now we see
moscow suggesting that diplomacy take
place at the barrel of a gun
or as moscow's rockets
mortars artillery
target the ukrainian people
this is not real diplomacy those are not
the conditions for real diplomacy
oksana markarova the ukrainian
ambassador in washington says they are
gathering evidence of possible war
crimes
ukraine has been victim of unprovoked
aggression by russian federation
the second day was even harder
the attacks have been more brutal
but i'm very pleased to say that they
were not successful
definitely not successful
as the enemy planned them
the decision to sanction vladimir putin
is a significant escalation but the
white house says it still has more tools
in its toolbox and will judge what's
needed day by day
alan fisher al jazeera at the white
house